my name is Alice Markham and I'm a
taxidermist I literally arrange skin
over sculptures that I
create my joke is that like most little
girls I grew up and wanted to be a
taxidermist but that's a
joke I was working for Disney and I just
kind kind of wound up hating my job a
bit I just wanted to do something with
my hands so I went to Taxidermy school
in Montana and the rest is a little bit
of
History I do commissions for television
film photo shoot that's kind of my bread
and butter there what I do is create say
sleeping cats or dogs that got hit by
cars if you don't want to have a live
animal on set but you need to look like
for a second there's an animal there
then that would be
me
tonight we're having an event here I'm
going to be skinning a white bangled
tiger cuup I received as a gift from a
zoo I had so many people asking me can I
watch you skin it can I watch can I
watch that I just figured I would sell
tickets the entire skin is going to kind
of lift off like a sweater skinning
something takes um for me a a
mediumsized mammal should be a couple of
hours taxit for me is science and art
being like a VIN diagram and that's
where they meet and that's what I love
about it most I love that there is a
right and there is a wrong and it either
looks like a peacock or a raccoon or a
kudu or it doesn't let me kind of
stretch it out a little bit so you guys
can see I think a lot of artists try to
think outside of the box and I'm a
little weird I'm trying to think inside
of the
box